after days of intense pressure attorney
general merrick garland finally speaking
out on the fbi's unprecedented rate on
former president donald trump's home
garland defending the justice
department's actions but did not take
any questions the attorney general
saying he personally approved the
warrant to carry out the raid and has
filed a motion to unseal it
the justice department has filed a
motion in the southern district of
florida to unseal a search warrant and
property receipt
relating to a court approved search that
the fbi conducted earlier this week
that search was a premises located in
florida belonging to the former
president
copies of both the warrant and the fbi
property receipt
were provided on the day of the search
to the former president's council
who is on site during the search
upholding the rule of law means applying
the law evenly
without fear
or favor
under my watch that is precisely what
the justice department is doing
i personally approve the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter
garland also defending the fbi from
criticism and how it carried out the
search of trump's home
let me address recent unfounded attacks
on the professionalism of the fbi and
justice department agents and
prosecutors
i will not stand by silently when their
integrity is unfairly attacked
the men and women of the fbi and the
justice department are dedicated
patriotic public servants
that comes as a source says that
president trump complied with a subpoena
issued for classified records in the
spring and it's unclear why the fbi did
not just issue another subpoena as trump
and his team were quote cooperative and
turned over documents okay i think the
big issue today is besides finding out
uh for a fact that merrick garland the
attorney general did approve
uh the issuance of the warrant is that
there is no information as to why they
chose to
request a search warrant based on
probable cause regarding
something from the presidential records
that is not in a criminal statute but
the issue is why they went so far as a
search warrant as opposed to simply
issuing another subpoena or getting a
court-ordered subpoena what say you
jesse
he owns it this guy garland he says he
called it so it's on him now we all know
biden was involved you don't do this
without the president knowing but he's
on vacation with hunter so we'll never
hear from them ever
again he comes out and everyone's
looking around the television like what
is he going to say what is he going to
say what is he going to say he says
nothing
he says i approved it but i can't say
anything but my guys aren't crooked oh
really oh really your guys aren't
crooked well all right let's see the
last time they planted evidence on trump
which was the dossier and they doctored
evidence to get the warrant and lied to
the judge for it so now we're supposed
to trust you guys it's not how it works
and now he's going to say oh let's we're
going to release the effort we're going
to release the warrant and stuff like
that
he's already being sued
in florida by judicial watch
they're the ones trying to get some
transparency he doesn't know what he's
talking about now
if you have an administration the obama
administration that spied on the trump
campaign
inserted moles into the trump campaign
and wiretapped the trump campaign
and then you have a biden administration
that raided trump's house
and
had raided his lawyer's house and seized
people's phones and shackled them and
gave him full body cavity searches
did they do that to any democrats
can you name
any high-profile democrats whose have
their home rated their phone seized
their computer sees anything
they only lock up republicans they only
do this to trump republicans so you
don't have the benefit of the doubt here
you've cooked up phony warrants you've
worked with dirty prosecutors worked
with dirty cops the democrats are all in
this together so i don't trust you the
country doesn't trust you it's now he
said she said apparently they were
cooperating for about a year
and trump actually poked his head and
said hey guys
there's some boxes you want to take a
look have have at it
you have to show intent remember that
what they said about hillary you have to
show intent
where's the intent he was cooperating
they had lunch at mar-a-lago when they
came by a few times everything was
copacetic they probably took a dip in
the pool
what's the big deal the next thing you
know you have guys with guns show up
way way too heavy-handed and now they
own it well you know what's interesting
is that those same guys told the
president to double lock the area to
protect the records and then they broke
the law and then they broke the law
harold harold what do you say about the
fact that
for the first time in the history of
this country we're raiding the home of a
foreign of a former president a
potential political opponent of a
sitting president never been done
in american history it takes four days
for the attorney general to come out and
own it because newsweek said he didn't
do it he wasn't involved in it i mean
why is it that we've got to go this far
for
this kind of information come out which
is basically i approved it but don't ask
me anything more the president of the
united states former president united
states for nine hours
the other night had
the search warrant
and the receipt
uh his lawyers and he did he had access
to it he told his friends for the life i
can't understand why he would tell his
friends and allies he didn't have it but
i'll come back to that
the point with this attorney general
today
i thought it was something that probably
should have happened a day ago
but he had no obligation to do it
because judges you well know and i'm
not a trained lawyer like you are but
i'm a graduate of law school
the federal investigators don't comment
on ongoing investigations
now i've heard some criticism today
still about the attorney general and
people wanting to know more
i want to know more also but there's an
investigation underway now president
trump is innocent until proven otherwise
in fact he hadn't been charged with
anything
i was glad to see attorney general also
explain to that to the country that this
was a court approved search warrant
that had all the required information
that a court
asked for in order to around probable
cause in order to do this
don't mistake or misconstrue what i'm
saying anyone around the table i'm not
rooting against the president but what i
don't for the life meal come back to
where i started if the president had the
warrant
had the receipt
why would you tell your friends
and your supporters that you didn't have
it
and blame and attack
fbi agents and other federal officials
for the life of me i don't i don't quite
understand that but i'm hopeful and
prayerful that as this investigation
goes forward uh that if the president
will have an opportunity to i hope
express himself you might all of us
probably know the president has until
three o'clock tomorrow to respond to the
court in florida
regarding whether or not they should
unseal the warrant and the receipt
now i don't know why he would wouldn't
just say right now release it he has
until tomorrow to do it the receipt
and the warrant are going to give us i
believe some answers to some of the
questions that we have around this table
and some of the questions that have been
asked it is up to the court at this
point to release it and the court will
make that decision on monday but no no
but i don't know you're not right they
gave the the trump team has not said
they want to release it right and the
court will decide based upon what
happens tomorrow the court ultimately
decides but the president said he didn't
have the warrant or the receipt two days
ago they told friends about it the issue
was they are saying that they were shown
the warrant that the attorneys who were
on site from 12 feet away but that's
neither here
i'm so confused by this i was under the
impression that we're
really it's about the affidavit and not
the warrant are you guys that's what
that's the question i'm going to ask you
we can talk about the the search warrant
because i've signed them till the cows
come home we can talk about the
inventory the only thing that matters is
the basis upon which the warrant was
issued what was this judge told that
would give him probable cause to say a
crime was committed on something that is
not a criminal act the presidential
records act unless maybe it's about
something else i don't know i don't know
is that the question i was just making
the point that that a lot more p i think
it's about the affidavit and not the
warrant
but anyway anyway judge what's an award
you've said you signed warrants what's
in the warrant
what's in the water in the water
i'm only saying that they should release
the warranty let's uh i want to talk
about that i don't mean interrupt right
that's all right merrick garland says we
had to do this because we couldn't do it
any other way that's what you call
circular nonsense i'm sorry your honor i
had to kick the dog because i couldn't
not kick the dog so that was basically
he's a perfect bureaucrat i'm glad he's
not a supreme court judge he came off
pretty badly as about the when he
describes the fbi as patriotic servants
i would agree but who else are patriotic
servants the irs agents and we've been
making fun of the irs since 1862
and the fact is that is our right to
criticize patriot patriot patriots and
non-patriots alike uh the things we say
about lawyers we've been saying for
thousands of years we've been wishing
harm on them so
this idea that
we
cannot criticize or denigrate anyone for
fear that someone else in this country
will do something crazy in two words
screw you because that is a trick to
shut you up they're basically saying oh
how dare you you can't do that no no no
we actually can and coming from people
in the media who delighted in the orgy
of police denigration as violence was
actually occurring as the riots and arts
were happening and saying horrible
things and then you have the media and
you have the fbi monitoring social media
for threats looking at uh uh
online message boards that is the
equivalent of monitoring every sporting
event for heckling you know if you want
to find that threat
or opinion or anything you can find it
if i bet i could find a death threat
against dana perino i bet i could it's
probably from kilmeade but i'm telling
you if you want if you want to look at
for something like that you are going to
find it so this is just this is just
kind of a a way to keep you to keep you
from talking the amazing story about
this is what if nothing is there what if
it really is about bland documents how
bad does garland look then about making
a mountain out of a mohill if they don't
have a picture of trump making out with
putin this is a bust
you know what's amazing though they can
dump on cops as serial racist murderers
but don't you dump on the fbi okay so
dana i go back to you with the original
question the requirement is that they
use the least intrusive means available
to seize evidence and there is nothing
especially with a history of cooperation
a history of the handing over 15 boxes
that suggests that court order wouldn't
have worked yeah and also it was strange
in this day and age we have no video
we remember when they they told them to
turn off the cctvs and the videos okay i
was told that by eric trump right so
however it happened we have no video we
don't even have video of the fbi
arriving do you remember when they went
after roger stone's house they alerted
cnn okay so merrick garland is saying
and that's kind of clever right he's
like
we didn't nobody even had to know
because we didn't say anything the
president's one who made it public but
that was the president's prerogative to
do that as well
the everything that merrick garland said
today could have been said in a written
statement on monday night and then you
wouldn't have had the newsweek story
that everyone was talking about how
great this newsweek story is turns out
it's not true they said that merrick
garland didn't even see it never even
now merrick garland has to come out and
say actually i did they could have done
that on monday night after the president
revealed the information and then you
wouldn't have him in front of the
cameras not answering um questions from
the press there's a reason that merrick
garland is at the top of the list that
for republicans that if they take back
the house they want to investigate
you're talking about the schools
remember domestic terrorists you're
talking about the fact that they did not
do anything at the justice department to
protect supreme court justices who are
being attacked and judicial crisis
network they just put out a million
dollar ad talking about that that's
before this even happened and that all
just happened today and so um the last
thing i'll say because in the b block
we're going to talk about the white
house and i've got thoughts about that
if i don't understand how a document
can be this
critical like unless it has
you want the picture you're saying if it
does a picture of putin and trump making
out yes
short of the nuclear codes being written
on these documents in a locked behind
closed doors
i just really don't understand how a
document could warrant this kind of
warrant right and especially since they
have to identify where it is you know
they had to say it was in melania's
dress or something for them to go
through her clothing but that's another
issue hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else